hello my name is andrew you might
recognize me from the show worth it
where i taste
foods at different price points with my
buddies adam and steven
in this video series i attempt to
recreate my favorite things
i had on worth it try to better
understand what makes great food really
delicious today it's
cold fried chicken as in temperature
cold fried chicken the worth it fried
chicken sandwich episode we had this
spicy
cold fried chicken from a place called
fuku it was both exhilarating
oh oh oh
oh wow and it's fascinating that it was
very tasty despite being a cold piece of
meat this fried chicken
is actually based on a dish from another
restaurant that has not previously been
unworth it momofuku
but i've eaten that before actually with
adam and annie after a shoot once the
original cold fried chicken is not spicy
but possibly one of my favorite things
i've ever eaten i think
making this dish is going to help me
with something that i'm really curious
in which is
the fundamentals of why something tastes
good
holy sh cold fried chicken sounds
counterintuitive
and yet this dish is undeniably
delicious to start off i'm going to be
speaking
with the executive chef from momofuku co
chef shawn gray
i'm really curious about this cold fried
chicken that you guys are
pretty famous for now it kind of came
from two different places one of which
was this like running joke that we
wanted to have
a restaurant that served food that was
already all prepared
and then we were doing this private
dinner thought we would just do like a
fried chicken spread
the dinner was going on like much longer
than we anticipated and we kept frying
the chicken like in these
short bursts to keep it nicely fresh for
when it did go out
leftover chicken we put it in the
walk-in and towards the end of the night
everyone kept going in and out of the
walk-in just eating this chicken and i
was kind of like yo maybe we could
actually surf this like maybe this could
be a thing
everyone else working here was really
amped up about it having like a
relationship
to it of you know eating cold chicken
like out of your fridge like late at
night
just very satisfying you know we spent
the next month really working on the
recipe really working out the flavors
from a flavor and texture standpoint why
does it work
cold well i think with chicken and
especially like cooked proteins all of
the juices and all of like that fat and
collagen and all that kind of stuff
stays in the meat versus like cutting
into you know roasted chicken it's gonna
steam out or it's gonna
lose some more moisture content right no
that makes a ton of sense you know and
then you pick it up and it's like
refrigerator temperature
i can't think of any other cold foods
that have that kind of like mild crunch
like a
65 crunch i don't know it's just in
between texture it's like soft and
crunchy at the same time
is the cold fried chicken available
right now we're doing the chicken
uh it's a go item we've been working a
lot on pizzas so we're trying to have
like everything would just be going
yeah no problem
is there one right in front of you could
you pan down and show me
no it's gone no problem well thanks so
much for chatting really excited to make
this chicken yeah i'm excited to see how
it comes out
okay sean helped me out with some of the
details of the recipe
so far one of the most curious aspects
to me is what is happening
inside the meat of the chicken to start
we're making this brine
first ingredient of which is liquid koji
from what i understand
koji is the fermentation agent in making
sake that same fungus is also used to
make soy
sauce and miso i think in this recipe
it's going to be doing
a job similar to buttermilk which is to
tenderize the meat and then just a bunch
of water and then i put chicken in
i put a tiny plate on top to make sure
everything stays submerged
okay so i'm going to cover this up
so this will brine for many hours and
then it'll be time for frying
oh god this is gonna be a horrible shape
to fit in my refrigerator
so the chicken's been brined i also
pulled it from the brine
and let it sit in the refrigerator
uncovered for a while to dry the
exterior
so before we fry the chicken there's a
couple other elements we need to make
first there's a finishing salt this is
just a seasoned salt with
nothing crazy in it you know it's garlic
powder onion powder cayenne
stuff like that in here really not even
a cream yet
come on finishing salt is pretty
interesting to me because it's not
really
a step of cooking that i think about
usually the only thing that falls into
that category for me is like
cheese other finishing element of the
fried chicken
is a glaze for once it's done frying
okay welcome to the stove
area water and sugar a little bit of
salt
soy sauce this all comes together now
this glaze is a prime example of how
what i'm able to do at home is going to
differ a little bit from what they do at
the restaurant
because i'm not able to find the exact
same ingredients i should still be able
to get
a glaze from my chicken that will be
pretty flavorful
last thing we're adding is green hot
sauce
and yuzu koshu yuzu is this citrus
yuzukoshu
is this japanese fermented product
very citrusy i don't know if like pine
tree
resin was delicious and that's that
it's salty sweet it's a little spicy
makes me want to do this this has cooled
down
i can now set this aside for when i'm
done frying the chicken
so now it's time to make the dredge and
the batter combination of
wheat flour and rice flour in corn
starch which i believe
will help make a crunchier final chicken
i really like the way that flour smells
it's a very cozy smell to it it reminds
me of
a pantry oh god
we're in the wrong color for this okay
god this is going to be the dredge for
the chicken as well as the dry
ingredient for the batter and then the
liquid elements which
are beer and vodka alcohol is the
primary
liquid in this batter i believe because
it will
evaporate faster resulting in a crispier
texture this needs to go in the fridge
to stay very cold
we'll set up the frying oil and then
dredging batter
right before frying welcome to the fry
zone so we have to fry this chicken
four times and the first time is going
to be just in our flour
dredge and into the oil each time it's
at
a different specific temperature the
interesting thing is that it's
relatively
low this happens for just three minutes
small kitchen problems i need to have a
place for this chicken to land so we're
going to go right here
onto a wire rack okay so i'm turning my
oil off for now because the chicken
needs to cool
before the next batter and fry you can
see
where some of my chicken came in contact
with the bottom of the pot he got a
little hotter than probably
is desirable so there's also specific
instruction to
turn the chicken over after a few
minutes flipping it will help
more evenly drain the chicken i guess so
far this is unlike
any way i've ever cooked meat so i don't
know if i'm doing well or not the
chicken is down to
room temp so it's time to pull the
batter from the fridge
batter it get this back in the fryer the
fryer temperature is now
a little bit higher up to 3 30.
oh no don't stick together
okay these are getting quite dark so i'm
gonna pull them out of the fryer
i feel like mine have gotten very dark
very quickly
they are quite crispy sounding already
though
same thing is going to happen here i'm
going to flip them after a few minutes
in other news i did not really
understand how long this was gonna take
and it's almost nighttime now we wait
another 15-20 minutes
fry number three get the batter out of
the fridge chicken back in the batter
and into the fryer so each of these
fries should take between
two and a half and three minutes
depending on the color
i'm just bobbing these babies up and
down okay i'm pulling these bad boys out
these are starting to look like what i
recall
the chicken in the restaurant looking
like
the thickness of the shell not all of
them
are evenly so in my small pot they're
kind of bumping into each other
and now we wait another couple minutes
flip them again let them rest evenly
ooh can you hear that it's like gravel
jeez now just let these cool some more
and then the last fry
damn it i've overshot the heat a little
bit
it's time for the final fry
this process reminds me of a
blacksmith's job in
perfecting steel it needs to be heated
and cooled very carefully to achieve the
right hardness if it's too hard
it'll be brittle and break on the first
use but if it's not hard enough then
it won't serve its purpose okay so it's
the very end of the day it's getting
quite dark
last thing to do is to glaze the chicken
so the instructions to do this in one
swift motion
[Music]
it's very difficult not to eat freshly
made fried chicken
i'm gonna pack these away and uh
try them tomorrow before i pull out the
fried chicken i'm gonna set up my plate
and i think i can make it look pretty
close to what they do at the restaurant
so first
they actually have some pickles on the
plate and at code they pickle their own
cucumbers but
i'm just gonna use my favorite dill
pickle so i'm just gonna do
a couple piled off to the side now the
chicken they look
pretty accurate to me you can see where
the batter has really
puffed up and achieved a shell but you
can tell they're not
as even as would have been ideal
now to do the finishing salt
so i believe at the restaurant you order
them per piece at the time
there were three of us so we got three
pieces so i'm going to replicate
that plate at first glance it looks very
good but the closer you look you can see
how uneven the batter and the frying was
now i eat it
the flavor is incredible it's a little
sweet
it's a little spicy very flavorful
throughout the whole thing
and it being cold really has the effect
of being
like a treat how do i think i did mine
is not even
close to the one at co but that's to be
expected i mean co is an amazing
restaurant i think all of the food that
they do there has an incredible amount
of
thought and attention and patience put
into it
it's a very interesting recipe to go
through i mean it makes you think
a lot about why anything you eat
is the way that it is if you'd like to
try an actually good version of this
fried chicken i highly recommend
visiting co
and having it for yourself it is really
a one-of-a-kind
unique treat
[Music]
[Music]